and the other issue is once you've had
five Partners as a chick your chance of
a happy marriage drops to 20 30 and this
is the problem even if you escape
even if if some Sim bails you out of
your bad decision the truth of the
matter is the person that it hurts the
most really is ourselves because
promiscuity uh basically means that your
chance of a happy marriage is very slim
um you know if you were going to take a
pill in that pill you had a 80 chance of
dying a 70 chance of dying you probably
wouldn't take that pill but it's
interesting because women will take the
promiscuity pill for over a decade and
then wonder why they're in the situation
that they're in you know so